hey there tone skaters and welcome back
to my channel
if this is your first time here i want
to give you a big welcome and thank you
so much for coming today
do me a huge favor and hit that like
button and share this video with other
people if you think they would enjoy it
it'll help me out a lot and i really
appreciate it
but today i want to show you the tour
for chapter six of connecting small
towns i just finished chapter seven
today and i'll upload it this week but
until then i hope you all enjoyed the
chapter six
session it was a really big build but i
had a lot of fun building it
um it was really really great but before
i leave you with the tour i just want to
thank you all for coming by
and showing me some love this week i'm
almost at 150 subscribers i'm currently
at 147
and i'm really excited about that so i
really really appreciate it like thank
you guys so much again um if you enjoy
my work and you're looking for other
ways to support me you can do so by
clicking one of the links in the
description below
one link will take you back to my home
page just click the link and once you're
on my page you've helped me out
also if you have the brave browser you
can support me by viewing my videos via
brave if you don't have the browser and
you would like to support me this way
the link is also in the description
but of course the most effective way to
support me is to subscribe as i'm on the
road to 500
and i'm pretty much almost halfway there
i know it's like 250 so i need about 100
more before halfway there but
help me out help me out a lot if you
would just go on ahead and hit that sub
button or if you know someone that would
like my content
send them my way and encourage them to
subscribe as well anyways
as i stated in previous episodes this
series is pretty much me just connecting
small towns
i'm playing with the grid seeing how
things generate as i work through it
it's really nice to see the way some
combinations work if you haven't seen
this chapter you just want to view it
again the video will be
in the cards in the upper right corner
of the video along with some other cards
please be sure to check out that stuff
as there's some good stuff in there if
you do like it hit the like button
subscribe and share with your fellow
youtube friends because once again it
will really really help me out a lot but
anyways that's all for me
enjoy the video thank you for viewing
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey there townscaper if you're hearing
this and that means you made it to the
end i just want to thank you so much for
viewing it's greatly appreciated make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
make sure you hit that like button
because that will help me out a lot
also you can follow me on instagram and
twitter the links are down in the
description below
and again i just want to say thank you
so much for checking in and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye